qui voyage 5 fois plus vite que la
vitesse du son avec leur hangar à côté
de chez vous
des bureaux aéroportés somptueux dans
les cabines sont tapissées de soie
pour moins d'un million de dollars vous
pourrez acquérir un jet parfois même
conduit par un héros de Star Trek
maintenant entrons dans l'univers des
jets privés
[Musique]
les jets privés ont toujours été le
domaine des riches et célèbres les
propriétaires de jet comme Tom Cruise et
John Travolta s'en servent pour leurs
affaires ou juste pour leur plaisir mais
en dehors de ce marché il existe celui
des avions innovateurs chers et
sophistiqués dont seuls les grands
trusts financiers ont accès
[Musique]
Marc cubaine est devenu milliardaire en
1999 quand il a vendu son broadcast.com
au moteur de recherche internet Yahoo
pour pratiquement 6 milliards de dollars
avant que le marché technique ne
s'écroule
avec sa nouvelle fortune marque s'est
offert trois achats extravagants un
château de 7200 mètres carrés l'équipe
de basketball de sa ville natale Dallas
Mavericks et le jet privé golf stream
five et ce pour une seule raison
[Musique]
le temps le temps le temps le temps
celui que nous ne pouvons jamais acheter
ni réclamer ni reprendre celui que vous
ne pouvez ni condenser ni jamais modifié
une fois qu'il s'est envolé c'est trop
tard ayant des pensées tendeurs assis à
attendre sur une piste d'envol ou dans
un aéroport et à la minute où je me suis
trouvé financièrement capable de changer
tout cela je n'ai pas eu d'hésitation ni
des datas
[Musique]
après avoir fait quelques recherches sur
le net le cubain a choisi le Game stream
five il est alors acheté par internet
pour 41 millions de dollars c'était le
plus grand achat connu de l'histoire il
ne sait même pas posé la question
si je m'offre un jet c'était lui
je pense que j'ai volé sur un jet privé
peut-être trois ou quatre fois avant
d'en acheter un et la première fois que
je l'ai eu j'ai eu la super sensation
d'être comme une rock star
pour 41 millions de dollars marquent a
reçu le modèle G5 de base un modèle
volant à une altitude de 13500 mètres
presque 3000 mètres de plus qu'un jet
commercial avec une altitude maximale de
15 500 mètres il vole à Max 0,85
c'est-à-dire 930 km/h il a une envergure
de 30 mètres et peut transporter 19
passagers
[Musique]
le plus perfectionné c'est comme
l'ordinateur le plus puissant dont vous
ne vous seriez jamais servi c'est très
passionnant de voir ce qu'il peut faire
il est parfait il vole haut il vole vite
il fait tout ce que le pilote veut faire
un pilote de G5 tient au bout de ses
doigts la puissance de deux moteurs dans
des jet les plus performants jamais
construit
le golf stream 5 est équipé d'un des
moteurs les plus puissants le BMW
Rolls-Royce
br71040h qui est un moteur très large un
mètre 20 il est capable de grimper plus
vite et plus haut et de maintenir son
cap avec plus de facilité que n'importe
quel autre moteur de golf stream
mais Mark Kuban voulait avoir des
accessoires électroniques
supplémentaires une des premières choses
dont vous ayez envie la prise TV car
vous voulez faire de ce jet personnel la
maison que vous aimez donc nous avons
pris rendez-vous avec les ingénieurs de
Honeywell où nous avons acquis un écran
TV plat de 8 pouces que nous avons monté
à l'arrière de l'avion
Marc était aussi soucieux de la sécurité
il y avait donc une caméra montée sur la
queue de son G5
de l'intérieur de la cabine une simple
poussée d'un bouton active la caméra en
envoyant un signal vidéo à tous les
moniteurs intérieurs
n'importe quoi s'approchant de l'avion
serait immédiatement détecté
ils peuvent tout surveiller devant leur
moniteur personnel juste devant eux les
pilotes peuvent aussi l'utiliser pour
regarder tous les contrôles du vol
des extrêmes de son G5 volent plus haut
et plus vite des sauvegardes ont été
intégrées en cas de décompression
catastrophique de la cabine
si le pilote n'était pas assez rapide
pour saisir son masque à oxygène même si
l'avion voyagé seulement à 5500 mètres
il pouvait quand même perdre
connaissance en effet la concentration
de l'oxygène dans l'air diminue avec
l'altitude affaiblissant gravement les
fonctions du cerveau
[Musique]
à la fin des années 40 quand les avions
sont devenus capables de voler une
altitude de plus de 3000 mètres les
avions se sont tous équipés de cabines
pressurisées le refroidissement du
moteur s'effectue à travers un
compresseur un échangeur de chaleur
refroidit l'air qui est alors pompé par
un filtre circulant à travers la cabine
une valve d'écoulement à l'arrière de
l'avion laisse sortir l'air afin qu'une
pression atmosphérique correspondant à
une altitude de 1800 mètres puisse être
maintenu dans la cabine
[Musique]
aujourd'hui la F1 exige que tous les
pilotes utilisent leur masque à oxygène
s'ils veulent au-dessus de 3700 mètres
durant 30 minutes ou plus
[Musique]
quand le lien jet 35 que golfeur Payne
Stewart a fêté s'est écrasé près de
minotes dans le Dakota du Sud la cause
de cet accident fut attribuée à une
dépressurisation de la cabine cependant
la raison n'a jamais été déterminée
[Musique]
les concepteurs d'avions ont commencé à
renforcer le système de sécurité afin
qu'à la moindre alerte de décompression
remarquée par les instruments l'avion
peut descendre de son altitude maximum
en seulement 2 minutes et demi
35 a été construit en 1979 avant que ce
renforcement dans le système de sécurité
ne soit disponible en fait la
technologie de la sécurité de l'avion a
fait des progrès remarquables dans les
10 dernières années comme tous les
avions le golf stream five de marque
cubaine est équipé avec un système de
sécurité extrêmement pointu qui prévient
du moindre danger il donne un signal au
pilote s'il perçoit quoi que ce soit
d'anormal dans sa ligne de vol
vous êtes quelque part en Amérique du
Sud dans les Andes et vous trouvez dans
la situation où l'avion s'est éloignée
de son cap la sécurité vous indique le
relevé du terrain et la distance au sol
de tout espace montagneux de la région
en une minute il vous préviendra si vous
survolez un pic montagneux il vous donne
l'image de ce que vous pouvez voir
réellement le pilote pourra leur
reprendre le contrôle de l'avion et
passer par-dessus les montagnes
on peut aussi attirer aux instruments
dans le cas d'une mauvaise visibilité il
permet au pilote de voir chacune des
images qui ne seraient pas visibles
normalement dans une situation de
visibilité nulle ou partielle tout cela
provient d'une amélioration du système
de l'atterrissage aux instruments le
premier depuis 1929 nommé système de la
vision rehaussée EVS qui fait appel à
plusieurs composants notamment un
appareil photo infrarouge et une caméra
haute exposition ou HUD
[Musique]
la sonde infrarouge capte la chaleur et
l'énergie de l'extérieur et reproduit
ensuite tout le relief en images du
terrain par cette caméra haute
exposition
[Musique]
Mark Kuban était si heureux de son
premier jet qu'il a décidé d'en acheter
un autre un nouveau Boeing 757 200 jet
liner commercial serait parfait pour son
équipe de basket-ball
il voulait simplement que les joueurs
veulent confortablement pendant leur
déplacement
croyez-le ou pas le facteur clé de ma
décision d'acheter un avion 757 était sa
capacité de contrôler le menu le
deuxième paramètre était son côté
confortable et cette possibilité de
repos et de délassement après un match
contre Nil vous êtes épuisé vous êtes
fatigué vous avez envie de confort
[Musique]
les sont pas les premières équipes
sportives à s'être rendu compte du
bien-être de posséder leur propre jet
tout comme l'équipe floridas Orlando
Magic
[Musique]
les équipes athlétiques professionnelles
ont été historiquement parmi les
meilleurs clients des avions privés
initialement ils affrêtaient des avions
de ligne pour leur usage privé
quelques-uns le font encore mais le
changement dans les esprits afin d'avoir
son propre avion est en route avec leur
avion il voyage comme ils veulent ils
arrivent ainsi plus en forme sur le
terrain
les 12 joueurs des Magics et leur
entraîneur voyagent ordinairement dans
un Boeing 737 construit en 1987 pour 135
passagers
[Musique]
a été confié à Patrick Altuna au centre
de l'air associé de Dallas leurs tâches
et de concevoir et décliper à
l'intérieur sur des jets privés neufs ou
des jets précédemment installés comme
celui des Magics
[Musique]
sur les avions type jet sportif habituel
dans lesquels vous n'avez pas de chance
ni de salle de bain avec douche ou bidet
mais vous avez des cabines très
confortables ce qui correspondrait au
première classe des avions de ligne
régulière
vous savez avec une très bonne
insonorisation des divertissements
agréables et une très jolie décoration
en placage de bois
mais ce genre d'opulence ainsi que les
jets privés ne sont devenus des produits
courants que dans les 20 dernières
années il y a moins d'un siècle les
amateurs d'aviation avaient déjà un
grand plaisir à voler avec juste le bois
et la toile de leur coucou
ensuite sont apparus les premiers jet y
compris le Nord American saberline et le
jet star de noces le premier jet civil à
traverser l'Amérique
[Musique]
durant les 20 premières années du XXe
siècle le vol en avion était considéré
comme une expérience un peu folle et ne
passionnait pas beaucoup la recherche
[Musique]
mais en 1914 la Grande Guerre qui est en
sa fureur à travers l'Europe étant aussi
son combat dans le ciel ce combat aérien
a lancé une nouvelle industrie pilote
dessinateur d'avion et entrepreneur
se déterminé à faire de l'aviation une
partie vitale du paysage américain
à la fin de la guerre les États-Unis
semblèrent étouffer sous les avions de
guerre en surplus la plupart d'entre eux
étaient le JN 4 des Curtis biplan appelé
Jenny
les experts disent que 12000 avaient été
construits grâce à l'effort de guerre
mais plus de la moitié n'avait jamais
volé
c'est parce qu'il ne pouvait pas former
de pilotes assez rapidement ils ont
construit des avions plus vite qu'ils ne
pouvait entraîner les pilotes aussi
après la Première Guerre mondiale il y a
eu beaucoup de génie à vendre aux
États-Unis il les vendait
approximativement 300 dollars et les
gens les achetaient et il s'écrasaient
partout le Congrès a fini par demander
l'arrêt de la vente
dans le Kansas est rapidement devenu la
capitale aérienne mondiale c'était une
région qui développait trois industries
majeures et qui bénéficient de l'essor
des voyages d'affaires aéroportés cela
pour plusieurs raisons le pétrole le
bétail et le réseau autoroutier c'était
une ville qui a revendiqué une grande
population d'habiles techniciens et
d'ouvriers habitués à ce salir pour
réparer leur machine agricoles de plus
la campagne était plate une pleine
ouverte aussi loin que l'oeil puisse
regarder
[Musique]
la végétation était suffisamment rare
pour permettre des atterrissages
sécurisés quelques-uns des plus grands
noms de l'aviation basèrent donc leur
nouvelle compagnie à Washita ses snaps
le marché principal de l'industrie des
petits avions dans les premières années
étaient plus florissant que de nos jours
c'était des gens avec des ressources de
l'argent et le besoin de couvrir de
grandes distances le plus vite possible
dans les années 20 ou 30 beaucoup
d'entre eux étaient des fermiers avec
des gros intérêts agricoles un peu
partout ainsi que des cadres de la
compagnie pétrolière
ce fut aussi le temps des fous volants
et des aventuriers souvent c'était
d'anciens pilote militaire homme qui ne
pouvait pas se résoudre à cesser de
voler
il volait vers une ville qui n'avait
aucun aéroport la survolait trouver un
champ et il pouvait atterrir à l'aveugle
étudier l'emplacement ils apprivoisaient
alors la terre et les gens afin de les
faire sortir et leur offrir une balade
dans le ciel ils ont ainsi gardé l'image
vivante de l'aviation de cette période
de la Guerre mondiale puis Lindberg a
fait son arrivée
avant que Charles Lindberg n'est
traversé l'Atlantique en 1927 les gens
étaient encore sceptiques sur la
sécurité en avion faire un long voyage
était quelque chose que la plupart des
cadres en affaires ne considéraient même
pas mais une fois que Lindberg est
accompli son exploit déjà en regardait
l'avenir de l'aviation d'un autre œil
ils y ont vu une meilleure technologie
et une conquête du ciel qui leur
permettait d'aller n'importe où
la traversée de l'océan Atlantique de
Lindberg a inspiré les aviateurs à
rivaliser les uns contre les autres dans
les courses aériennes les règles étaient
basées sur la vitesse l'endurance et les
distances
[Musique]
qui couraient durant cette période était
allé plus vite qu'aucun homme sur la
terre ne l'avait jamais fait quand il
gagnait le Cleveland air concert vous
savez il franchissait un nouveau record
à chaque fois cela devenait plus qu'un
sport car il développait de nouvelles
technologies
[Musique]
toutes les recherches étaient effectuées
pour rendre les avions plus puissants et
plus sûr simplifie les courbes du
fuselage pour permettre à l'avion une
meilleure entrée dans l'air avec le
moins de résistance possible on a
inventé des hélices mieux contrôlés avec
lesquels les pilotes pouvaient
positionner la lame de l'hélice sous le
meilleur angle pour augmenter la vitesse
et l'altitude
[Musique]
les appareils de pilotage automatique
ont été découverts rendant la navigation
plus exacte et permettant plus de repos
au pilote pendant les longs vols
la radio est améliorée permettant au
pilote de recevoir les directions de
navigation depuis le sol
[Musique]
à la fin des années 30 Hitler avait
envahi la Pologne et l'armée japonaise
marchait dans nangjing
[Musique]
les deux guerres mondiales étaient à
l'horizon à travers les continents
européens asiatiques et africains les
avions militaires ont été construits par
centaines et par milliers
[Musique]
pendant la deuxième guerre mondiale le
jet propulsé est devenu une réalité
pratique
[Musique]
le 22 août 1939 l’allemagne a fait voler
son premier jet il s'appelait UNKLE he
178 un turbo jet qui n'a jamais été
utilisé au combat
[Musique]
la compagnie d'avion Bel a construit le
premier avion à réaction américain en
1942 également pour l'armée
c'était un xp59a
era comète qui volait à une vitesse de
620 km heure
avec la fin de la guerre l'aviation
entrait dans la culture américaine les
enfants ont rêvé de devenir des pilotes
les pilotes les plus expérimentés se
sont reconvertis dans les possibilités
énormes du futur avion privé
il pensait que suite à la guerre les
gens auraient un avion dans leur garage
un avion dans chaque année que l'avion
de chaque homme serait celui qui
l'inventerait
indépendamment de cette optimiste Béa en
déclin aucun pilote ne renonça à la
détermination de créer son propre petit
avion
au loin de Witchita les plus ancien
constructeurs d'avions d'Amérique c'est
SNA beachcraft et people ont finalement
commencé à fabriquer de nouveaux avions
privés
et avec chaque nouvelle génération
d'avion les consommateurs demandaient
des modèles qui iraient plus loin plus
haut et plus vite
quelques compagnies ont commencé à
s'occuper de la vitesse et à se tourner
vers les avions militaires et les jet
commerciaux
c'est alors que survient un événement
dans le désert de Californie du Sud qui
selon quelques-uns fut le point de
départ du jet en 1957
[Musique]
c'était un week-end typique sur la base
militaire Edwards dans le désert de
moave
les vents balayer l'air ambiants quand
le premier Loki G-Star a troué l'air
chaud et sec par son premier vol c'était
seulement 241 jours après son achèvement
[Musique]
quand le jet star fut construit en 1957
ils se sont habitués à construire des
avions rapides pour l'armée de l'air et
à les essayer immédiatement
ne leur a pas fallu longtemps pour
envoyer le jet star dans les airs
tout l'avion a volé à plus de 480 km/h
en seulement 39 minutes le jet store un
turbojet était capable de transporter 10
passagers à leur destinations trois fois
plus vite que les avions à hélice
[Musique]
le moteur turbo du jet était réellement
le premier moteur aussi puissant il
utilisait des roues à compression
tournante à l'avant du moteur pour
comprimer l’air cet air était alors
brassée et ensuite il entrait en
combustion c'est le souffle du gaz
d'échappement qui propulsait le moteur
ainsi que les roues de la turbine à
l'arrière
[Musique]
le jet star était un avion unique pour
son temps il avait deux moteurs de
bonnes dimensions pour envoyer l'avion
dans les airs à la bonne vitesse à la
bonne altitude avec un parfait contrôle
du champ d'action beaucoup de son
arrangement intérieur en plus n'était
pas une apparence trop militaire
en tout locïd a construit 204 jet-star
beaucoup sont encore en service
aujourd'hui puis l'aviation a développé
le T39 saberliner en 1960 un jet
construit pour deux fonctions
différentes avions pour l'armée de l'air
américaines et pour la marine la version
civile est devenue l'un des concurrents
de jet star
durant leur vol autour du pays la double
recherche des militaires qui se trouvait
dans ses avions a permis de découvrir de
nombreuses techniques pour
l'amélioration de l'aviation civile ces
deux avions se sont avérés être parfaits
pour créer un niveau différent sur les
marchés des avions d'affaires
même si les jets d'affaires devenaient
de plus en plus sophistiqués Clyde sesna
et Walter Beach serait toujours les
pionniers de ce type d'avion par
certaines de leurs trouvailles
technologiques
ils étaient les précurseurs uniques pour
vendre ce concept de propriété de jet
privé à l'Américain moyen ensuite Bill
Lear inventeur et génie du marketing
démocratiserait la notion de jet privé
[Musique]
partout dans le monde le nom de lire est
toujours associé avec jet privé Frank
Sinatra ont possédé un le célèbre
golfeur Arnold Palmer a volé autour du
monde en jet Lear en 1976 et les
connaisseurs affirme qu'il a joué dans
plus de films et des missions de
télévision que n'importe quel autre
avion
[Musique]
les gens pensaient que tous les jets
d'entreprise était un leadjet et je
crois honnêtement qu'un type qui
marchait sur le trottoir le long d'un
aéroport s'il voyait un golf stream un
diable ou un jet star disait à son fils
tiens regarde ce sont des lires jet
parce qu'il avait souvent entendu
prononcé ce nom
comment se fait-il qu'un jet est plus
surpasser les autres à ce point et
devenir aussi célèbre et est-ce parce
qu'il représentait le premier avion
d'affaires au monde accessible à la
masse populaire mais peut-être était
tout simplement le charisme de son
concepteur et constructeur William
Powell lire né le 26 juin 1902 dans la
ville natale de Tom Sawyer Hannibal dans
le Missouri
lire déjà de l'essence se passionner
pour toutes sortes d'inventions
[Musique]
il a commencé par l'idée d'une radio de
voiture puis d'un magnétophone stéréo à
cassette et du pilote automatique pour
les jets il est même l'inventeur de la
radio télécommandée pour les avions de
laviation générale en tout Billère à
déposé plus de 150 brevets
déjà une certaine notoriété avant qu'il
ait même construit le lire jet mais le
lire jet a capturé l'imagination de
beaucoup de gens il était léger et
relativement économe il est devenu un
best-seller et à la fin plusieurs
milliers de dire jet furent finalement
vendus
en 1959 Billy possédait d'une entreprise
de construction d'avions dans le
Michigan appelé lire sigle mais quand il
a voulu construire un petit jet rapide
et bon marché ni son conseil
d'administration ni ses partenaires
financiers ni en cru quand ils ont
refusé d'approuver le projet il a donc
vendu ses parts de lire Siegler pour 14
millions et demi de dollars et il a
financé le jet lui-même
[Musique]
son fils Bill junior habitait en Suisse
et connaissait une petite compagnie
aérienne qui avait construit un petit
jet de combat le gouvernement suisse a
cependant décidé de ne pas le construire
Bill est allé partout il a prospecter il
a acheté cette compagnie il a commencé
le développement lire à partir de ce
prototype
il y a engagé ses propres deniers car
ils croyait en la réussite du marché des
avions privés et si cela avait mal
tourné il serait juste mort ruiné Bill
junior était un homme des grandes
convictions
et sa richesse personnelle
le prototype de lire pour le lire jet 23
a pris son envol le 7 octobre 1963 Billy
avait créé avec succès et contre toute
attente le premier jet américain
spécifiquement conçu pour les
entreprises civiles il se vendait 600
000 dollars
[Musique]
il a conçu le plus de l'âge pour 4 ou 5
passagers à 800 km/h et pour une
distance approximative de 2700 km
[Musique]
durant ces deux premières années de
circulation le lire jet 23 exploserait
le marché mondial le vol de Los Angeles
New York aller-retour a établi un record
de vitesse en couvrant la distance en 10
heures et 21 minutes
quelques mois plus tard le lire jet 23
Raffin de nouveau record de vitesse
quand il lui a fallu simplement 7
minutes et 21 secondes pour atteindre
12000 mètres d'altitude l'avion
transportait 7 passagers
était que le client pouvait choisir sa
destination contrairement aux lins
aérienne qui avait leur propre
itinéraire
heureusement car ces lignes aériennes
qui transportaient leur passagers à 800
km/h se développait de plus en plus et
se démocratiser Bill possédait une
grande qualité il avait su rester simple
l'avion avait juste la performance dont
il avait besoin mais il était plus léger
et meilleur marché que celui pour la
compétition
la première année le lire jet 23 a
accumulé 52 millions de dollars grâce à
ses ventes mais les avions étaient
fabriqués plus vite que la compagnie ne
les vendait et le coût de fabrication
des jets privés dépassé souvent le prix
que les clients étaient disposés à
mettre
[Musique]
et créancier de lire exigèrent bientôt
le remboursement de leurs
investissements et à la fin de l'année
1966 son affaire était au bord de la
faillite
le 10 avril 1967 lire a vendu sépare
majoritaire de la compagnie au Gates
Weber Company à Denver dans le Colorado
ils lui ont été payé 27 millions de
dollars finalement lire jet serait
acheté et vendu trois fois en 1992
bombardier in corporeation une compagnie
canadienne qui fabrique des motoneiges
aussi bien que des matériaux pour le
réseau routier rachète la compagnie pour
75 millions de dollars puis ce sera au
tour de Air Canada aujourd'hui plusieurs
nouveaux modèles Learjet sont sur le
marché y compris les lire jet 45 et les
le lire jette 60 a été décrit comme le
jet d'affaires équivalent à la Corvette
[Musique]
vous pouvez grimper à 12500 mètres ce
qui est une bonne altitude de croisière
dans la première heure de vol
habituellement pour un voyage
Transcontinental on monte après à 14 mm
[Musique]
ce qui veut dire que ce jet de base peut
voler sur une distance de 4900 km de Los
Angeles à New York sont sur ravitaillé à
une vitesse de croisière de 800 km heure
cette avion se distingue
particulièrement dans sa performance en
montée avec l'addition des moteurs pw305
ce qui est la particularité des liens
jet 60 cela donne une puissance dans la
montée le lien jet 60 est peut-être
parmi les premiers jet de sa dimension à
utiliser les moteurs de pratique 305
mais ils sont surtout considérés comme
révolutionnaire parce que le pw305
comprend un système appelé FADEC l'avion
est contrôlé par ordinateur plutôt que
par liaison mécanique entre le poste de
pilotage et le moteur tout se fait par
logiciel
pour cette performance ce ne sont plus
des câbles qui relient dorénavant les
manettes de gaz au moteur les moteurs
sont contrôlés par signaux électronique
envoyé des manettes des gaz à travers un
ordinateur jusqu'au moteur il prévoit
une manipulation plus simple et un
moteur plus économe et plus précis grâce
à l'usage de la technologie numérique
mais avec ces signaux électroniques
dirigeant l'avion que se passe-t-il en
cas d'une augmentation anormale de
puissance ou pire d'un court-circuit
toute cette technologie ne pouvait être
certifiée qu'après l'assurance d'une
parfaite maîtrise de l'organisation les
chemins sont nombreux pour des données
voyageant entre les ordinateurs et les
récepteurs
le lien jet 60 ne fournit pas seulement
toutes les caractéristiques d'une
sécurité optimale il est aussi
incroyablement confortable il transporte
6 passagers d'un côté à l'autre et pour
un jet de petit taille bombardier pense
qu'il possède des avantages
considérables pour le passager
vous pouvez regarder un film profiter
d'un repas chaud ou vous étendre et
dormir si vous le souhaitez vous pouvez
organiser un groupe de conférences en
une réunion privée ce sont toutes ces
caractéristiques et avantages que les
passagers trouvent le plus attirant
Learjet 45 étant des premiers jet à
avoir été conçu exécutés et développer
uniquement par ordinateur il est
considéré comme un jet léger cependant
il est certifié pour voler à une
altitude de 15300 mètres c'est le seul
avion de sa catégorie à pouvoir voler
aussi haut et si vous étiez intéressé
par l'achat d'un de ces avions vous
pourriez acheter le lire jet 60 pour 12
millions de dollars alors qu'un 45 ne
vous coûtera que 9 millions et demi de
dollars
j'ai passé plus de la moitié de ma vie à
penser et à développer les lire jet ce
sont vraiment des engins fantastiques il
possède tout ce qu'il faut dans un avion
par exemple vous pouvez aussi bien
décoller d'une piste courte de 900 m que
grimper directement à 15000 mètres vous
volez confortablement en bras de chemise
à une altitude ou dans l'armée il vous
faudrait une combinaison haute pression
en seulement deux trois heures vous
pouvez parcourir la moitié du pays sans
brûler autant de combustible que dans
tout autre avion compétitif
si
populariser le voyage en jet privé il
n'était cependant pas le seul innovateur
byzesna Walter Beach et lloydsterman
crée des petites jettes à la pointe du
progrès le site et le first one
[Musique]
aérien du XXème siècle
ce fut le lieu de naissance pour
quelques-unes des compagnies aériennes
les plus prospères des États-Unis c'est
ici qu'en 1925 trois aviateurs clite
sesna Walter Beach et Lloyd steam ont
formé une brève association et
construisirent l'avion d'acier au lieu
de la toile et du bois les découvertes
qu'il développeraient les compagnies
qu'il formeraient ensuite pousseraient
l'Amérique vers l'âge du jet
ils ont appelé leur entreprise du nom
travel hair ils se sont installés dans
le local d'un petit bâtiment loué au
centre ville de Washita le premier avion
conçu est construit sous leur nouvelle
bannière était un avion en acier qui
sous l'effort de guerre à pu bénéficier
du moteur au X5 une centrale électrique
standard de son temps l'avion s'est
vendu à 3500 dollars mais contrairement
à Bitche et asterman Clyde sesna a
toujours favorisé les monoplants il
était de plus convaincu qu'une aile en
quand il est vert était réalisable
ce désaccord fondamental a entraîné la
démission de Cessna de travel air
seulement deux ans après le démarrage de
leur association
la séparation avec Beach et sterman se
fit à l'amiable en 1927 Clyde a vendu
ses parts de traveller pour 90% à 3
hommes d'affaires de Witchita il est
ensuite retourné à sa première idée
concevoir un avion monopolant avec une
aile en quantilever
l'aile en quand il est vert que Clyde a
promu n'avait pas de support et aucune
entretoise en fait elle pouvait
supporter 20 tomes et femmes qui sont
debout sur elle sur une photo juste pour
montrer la solidité d'un si petit
support
une aile en quand il est vert est
complètement supportée par une structure
interne c'est une structure d'un
assemblage symétrique de poteaux droits
et en croix sur le côté le dessin du
quand il est vert avait déjà été utilisé
avec succès dans les ossatures de pont
durant de nombreuses années
13 août 1927 le premier avion monoplan
aux ailes quand il est vert a gagné un
terrain de gravier près de Witchita dans
le Kansas et a pris son envol pour la
première fois
il a atteint une vitesse en l'air de
presque 160 km heure
aujourd'hui la plupart des avions se
servent encore de se descendre d'elle
ces SNA la baptisé le fantôme et a
commencé sa production les commandes
affluèrent
[Musique]
mais la Grande Dépression lui ferait
temporairement fermer son entreprise en
1934 son neveu Dwayne Wallace a remis
l'avion Cessna au goût de l'histoire de
laviation
deux ans avant 1932 Walter Beach et sa
nouvelle femme olive avait uni leurs
forces à l'ingénieur Ted Wells ensemble
ils ont fondé la Beach Aircraft Company
[Musique]
olive dirige l'affaire tandis que Walter
s'occupait lui-même du design de ses
avions en créant des avions à succès
comme le beachcraft Bonanza
malheureusement Walter Beach est mort à
l'aube de l'âge du jet au début des
années 50 au livre reprend seul la Beach
aircraft et bientôt elle va faire entrer
sa compagnie dans le monde des jets
civil en vendant des MS 760 un avion
français de quatre places au mot rain
Sonia
est entré le premier dans l'air des jet
avec son x-t37 avion qu'il a conçu et
construit son contrat avec l'armée de
l'air des États-Unis
c'était un petit jet à propulsion rapide
bimoteur il était très simple un pilote
et un instructeur pouvait se former en
juste une heure mais à la fin des années
60 c'est snack a commencé à sentir la
compétition de l'air
c'était aussi le temps de la fin des
moteurs à piston en faveur des turbos
qui gagne en popularité
[Musique]
cependant les pilotes adeptes du turbo
redoutaient le pas énorme que causerait
cette nouvelle découverte pour la
vitesse et l'altitude
[Musique]
la menace de lyre sert de catalyseur à
ces stars aircraft qui commence la
construction d'un nouvel avion équipé
d'un turbo
mais il va le créer de façon simple afin
que les pilotes intéressés par ce
nouveau concept puissent le piloter avec
seulement une petite formation
supplémentaire
en 1968 sessna aircraft introduit le
fanjet 500 c'est le premier jet
d'entreprise il est propulsé par un
moteur ventilateur turbo qui est
refroidi par un réel ventilateur placé à
l'avant de l'avion et qui produit
quelques poussées comme une hélice par
conséquent il amène de l'air en plus
grande quantité qu'un moteur turbojet la
pression est plus haute et donc claire
arrive à une température légèrement plus
haute aujourd'hui la plupart des jet
volent avec ce type de moteur
[Musique]
avec un poids brut de 4800 kg le funjet
500 pouvait transporter 6 passagers sur
plus de 21 000 km
le funjet 500 coûtait 600000 dollars et
finalement il est devenu l'un des jet
les plus populaires de tous les temps
en 1969 ce jet d'affaires a été
rebaptisé le site action en l'honneur du
cheval de course qui est gagné le Triple
Crown en 1948 il était très simple à
piloter des opérateurs et des pilotes
qui avaient volé sur bitchcraft King Air
et autres avions à hélice commander
l'ont trouvé d'une transition presque
trop facile il pouvait voler à 750 km
d'altitude et même plus ce qui était
remarquable pour un avion de deux
moteurs moyens un quart de siècle plus
tard en 1996 sesna a introduit le site
action 10 sur le marché c'était un avion
à faible résistance à l'air qui volait à
la vitesse de Mac 092 le jet d'affaires
le plus rapide du monde Los Angeles New
York en moins de 4 heures presque 2 km
en 6 monde plus rapide que tous les
ayons civils hormis le Concorde
le citation 10 à un des postes de
pilotage les plus perfectionnés dans le
monde en dehors de l'aviation militaire
il a le nouveau Newell Primus 2000
EFI
il mesure 21 cm sur 19 et possède des
écrans à tubes cathodique toutes les
fonctions exigées par l'avion sont
affichés
ce
Jetair sans jamais se ravitailler
n'importe qui peut s'en offrir un pour
juste un peu plus de 17 millions et demi
de dollars mais si cela dépasse votre
budget prenez un citation jet différents
celui de base qui coûte beaucoup moins
cher
il existe maintenant trois sous Modèles
le CJ le cj1 et le cj2 ils sont très
populaires parce qu'il est possible de
les piloter seul ils sont simples à
manœuvrer et possède une bonne marge
d'action
comparé aux citations 10 c'est plus
petit jet sont vraiment bon marché les
prix varient de 3 à 5 millions de
dollars
j'ai volé sur plus de 30 types d'avions
différents de toutes les variétés et
configurations et c'est l'avion le plus
facile que je n'ai jamais eu à piloter
peu de choses à faire pendant le vol les
listes de contrôle sont courtes le poste
de pilotage est très intuitif il est
vraiment amusant à piloter
mais vers la fin des années 70 l'intérêt
pour la l'aviation c'est un peu estompée
comme le prix du pétrole les ventes
d'avions privées ont chuté la femme de
olive a vendu Beach aircraft à la
corporation rayton une dizaine d'années
plus tard ils ont racheté Diamond jet à
Mitsubishi long amélioré et l'on
rebaptisé le Beach aircraft jet 400 a
ce jet atteignit des vitesses de 870
km/h et voler à une altitude de 13500 km
il transportait deux membres d'équipage
et jusqu'à 9 passagers
dans les années 90 right Horn à qui le
hawkerline de British air space ils
affirment que le jet le plus intéressant
sorti vainqueur de leur nouvelle
entreprise au cœur est un jet basique
appelé le first one
[Musique]
pour un prix de 10 millions de dollars
il n'y a vraiment rien qui pourrait nous
offrir un tel engin que le first one je
pense que c'est vraiment une excellente
combinaison entre une cabine spacieuse
et de moteur Williams
epj442 d'une immense puissance il
pourrait se comparer au Collins proline
21 avionic suite qui possède trois
panneaux de contrôle plat à cristaux
liquide dans le poste de pilotage ce qui
permet une grande facilité de guidage et
fournit plus de sécurité c'est l'un des
jets de base les plus convoités
actuellement
[Musique]
aircraft a construit à partir d'un
dessin original en utilisant des
matières composites les avions seront
plus légers plus fort et plus solides le
first one avec une autonomie de plus de
27000 km est conçu pour monter jusqu'à
une altitude de
12300 km ils veulent à 840 km/h et
transportent jusqu'à 6 passagers
le 11 août 2001 2 mois après le voyage
inaugural du first one le Hawker horizon
s'envole à son tour ce qui était
marquant pour ce premier vol de lorizon
c'était la première fois qu'un avion
était équipé du système premium x sweet
[Musique]
le Primus epic a bionique suite qui est
représenté dans l'horizon offre à
l'équipage de cinq personnes dix
panoplas à 8 cristaux liquides c'est
selon moi un système extraordinaire
d'exploitation de diagnostic conçu pour
fournir un montant maximal d'information
à l'équipage en réduisant la charge de
travail
[Musique]
dans son prix de 17 millions de dollars
étaient compris la peinture un intérieur
standard pour 8 passagers de larges
hublots et le premiumic Sweet
mais malgré ses nouveaux jets
disponibles clé en main certains en
veulent encore plus
améliorer l'équipement intérieur de la
viande
conversion en jet de prestige et une
possibilité de réfection totale si achat
de jet liners d'occasion
dans les acquéreurs de jet il se trouve
toujours des clients ne voulant pas de
modèle de base il cherche à obtenir
l'unique l'exceptionnel l'exclusif
c'est possible après une conversion
totale du jet par exemple vous pouvez
acheter un nouveau jet privé qui
s'envolera directement au centre de
réflexion pour rénovation de son
intérieur
où vous pourriez aussi acheter un jet
d'occasion et faire modifier non
seulement l'aménagement intérieur mais
aussi améliorer les performances
techniques
[Musique]
vous pourriez même acheter des jet
militaires usagés qui sont déjà
certifiés par la faha à différents
niveaux c'est ce qu'a fait Michael down
si vous ne le reconnaissez pas sans son
maquillage c'est le lieutenant Worf de
la série télé populaire Star Trek
Michael a aussi été pilote expert sur
les avions des années 30 un pilote sur
15 leçons puis il est passé pilote de
jet en 1992
je suis passé d'avion régulier Cesna un
moteur puis 2 puis au jet au jet
militaire ou jet de l'ex armé j'avais un
t33 puis un f86 ma passion est
maintenant pour les jet militaires
les premiers avions militaires furent
les bombardis de la deuxième guerre
mondiale
converti en transport pour les chefs
d'entreprise le premier grand jet
converti pour usage privé fut un 707 en
1961 il est maintenant plus connu sous
le nom de Air Force One
dans les années 50 un américain du Nord
a suggéré l'idée de prendre le saber jet
qui avait un design très populaire et
très fort et faire de cette alliance
civile un avion militaire et si vous
regardez cet avion et le f86 vous verrez
les mêmes design pour l'aile et les
trains d'atterrissage donc ils ont pris
toutes les meilleures choses du saber
jet et les ont incorporé dans cet autre
avion
le saberliner offre aussi un poste de
pilotage très spacieux une vitesse
incroyable et une remarquable autonomie
cet avion peut atteindre la vitesse de
Mac 1,2 ce qui représente environ 82% de
sa capacité il peut voler à une altitude
entre 1300 mètres et 15 500 mètres et
possède une autonomie de 23000 km il
offre donc la possibilité de vous
emmener où vous voulez au début c'est le
lire jet que je convoitais pour sa
vitesse d'enfer mais une fois que le
saberline est révisé il peut aller aussi
vite
si vous envisagez l'achat d'un jet
d'occasion Michael pour vous apporter
quelques conseils
quand vous avez envie d'un avion comme
celui-ci vous pouvez l'obtenir de
plusieurs manières vous allez voir un
courtier que vous connaissez et vous
achetez un journal sur les ventes
d'avion où vous vous connectez sur
aircraft.com sur le net il existe aussi
the controller qui est un autre magazine
spécialisé pour ce type d'avion ensuite
définissez votre objectif quel sera
votre plan de vol vous voulez vous
voyager sur une longue distance ou pas
et une fois que vous avez choisi votre
avion appelez le type et commencez les
négociations pour lesquelles vous avez
engagé un courtier et si vous êtes malin
vous aurez une pré-inspection avant de
conclure vous voyez la viande faites
dans le Tour seul inspectez le
minutieusement avant de vous assurer que
tout fonctionne puis vous revenez vers
le vendeur et si vous dites d'accord je
le veux il faut encore discuter c'est
comme cela que l'on doit faire
obligatoire et payante vous devrez faire
une inspection pour savoir si votre jet
est en bon état le saberline de Michael
a déjà été amélioré par une
climatisation il possède aussi un pilote
automatique et un système de
positionnement global d'après Michael un
avion de ce type pourrait se vendre
entre 350 000 et 800 000 dollars
[Musique]
la meilleure chose de ces avions et la
commodité qu'il vous offre vous n'avez
pas à vous battre avec vos bagages ni à
faire la queue pour les récupérer vous
ne devez pas traverser de terminale vous
pouvez arriver au plus près de votre
destination vous n'avez pas atterrir
forcément dans les grands aéroports vous
pouvez aller dans les tout petits
aéroports satellites
[Musique]
si vous n'avez pas une passion
particulière à voler dans les vieux jet
de l'armée reconvertie si vous voulez
quelque chose de nouveau et que vous
êtes disposé à des pensées beaucoup
d'argent alors tournez-vous vers le
centre de l'air associé à Dallas dans le
Texas voici une compagnie qui crée des
intérieurs de luxe pour jet
[Musique]
nous fonctionnons la plupart du temps
avec des clients qui nous apportent leur
avion avion que vous pouvez acheter neuf
à Boeing ou Airbus ou que vous pouvez
acheter à des loueur
une fois que le nouveau propriétaire a
acheté le jet initial l'avion est envoyé
au centre de l'air associée de lovefield
à Dallas
nous faisons ce que nous appelons une
conversion des pieds à la tête nous
transformons un avion de ligne régulière
qui arrive avec ses toilettes sont
galets et tout son équipement intérieur
mur latéraux casier et autres
et alors nous l'améliorons
nous le transformons en un VIP
DJ ou à votre Airbus acidji le
traitement royal comme des guides le
centre de l'air associé vous aidera à
prendre toutes les meilleures décisions
[Musique]
Forza
du client quels sont les transformations
qu'il veut effectuer de quel délai pour
les travaux disposons-nous cours ou long
s'il désire une chambre ou plutôt un
salon ou une pièce de réunion une salle
à manger
alors nous essayons d'avoir une idée du
budget pour que le client puisse
commencer à choisir les matériaux et les
pierres bois de placage et finitions et
plaquage des parties centrales un autre
aspect important pour nos clients le
divertissement donc nous nous asseyons
et tentons de définir combien de sources
combien d'aspects à regarder et combien
de moniteurs s'il y a lieu
[Musique]
Ron tutor président de tuteurs célibat
Corporation une compagnie internationale
de la construction désiré un Boeing BBJ
avec toutes l'élégance possible pour sa
famille et son affaire il a envoyé son
jet au centre de l'air associé les
ingénieurs et dessinateurs ont
transformé l'intérieur vide du bibiji en
une maison aéroportée de luxe idéal pour
une famille de quatre personnes il
pourrait servir de bureau aéroporté avec
pièce de conférence et suite de tel le
salon principal est conçu pour 12
personnes avec tous les gadgets
inimaginables pour les grands enfants
l'avion est équipé de quatre écrans
vidéos de moniteurs à écran plasma de 42
pouces un dans la cabine principale et
un dans la chambre supérieure vidéo par
des vidéos VHS sont disponibles
vous pouvez regarder deux vidéos
séparées à n'importe quel moment nous
avons un système audio sophistiqué où
vous pouvez passer divers CD avec casque
d'écoute à des postes différents et des
enceintes partout dans la cabine
le galet
offre d'une moderne équipé peut avoir
plaque de cuisson micro-ondes la
vaisselle four et même une machine à
expresso et cappuccino avec un membre de
l'équipage qui est un vrai chef
cuisinier entre le salon principal et le
galet voici un mini bar en marbre
toujours bien approvisionné
ici juste derrière se trouve la salle de
bain pour les invités et ce que nous
appelons une pièce des enfants pour les
directeurs
puis vient la suite du propriétaire avec
une grande chambre et une vaste salle de
bain équipée d'une douche
[Musique]
en fait il est aménagé comme une maison
mais ce n'est pas une maison
durant mes 9 années à travailler dans
une compagnie et maintenant 30 ans dans
mon affaire je n'ai jamais vu un
intérieur d'avion qui ressemble à un
autre
et fondamentalement c'est ce que les
gens cherchent l'exclusivité la touche
personnelle
[Musique]
pour une installation telle que celle-ci
il faut compter entre 12 et 15 millions
de dollars mais si vous ne pouvez pas
vous offrir à la fois un bibi 9 et 15
millions en plus pour son aménagement
intérieur envisager d'autres solutions
mais dans le Freemont au Colorado peut
vous construire votre jet et vous
l’équipez directement et fort
convenablement vous bénéficierez d’une
cabine de 2 mètres 50
il peut être configuré pour transporter
n'importe où 4 à 6 passagers
avec une autonomie estimée
approximativement à 2000 km ils volera à
une vitesse maximale de 700 km heure
il utilise un arbre moteur turbo
converti provenant de l'armée et
initialement fabriqué pour les
hélicoptères militaires
les moteurs de Maverick sont des t58
originairement conçus par Général
Electric mais apporte des modifications
il convertissent les arbres moteurs
turbo des hélicoptères en moteur turbo
pour jet
[Musique]
avec un plafond d'altitude de 9000
mètres cet équipement comprend aussi une
cabine pressurisée pour un achat comme
celui-ci votre propre avion avec votre
installation intérieure prévoyez selon
certaines modifications dans les 650 000
dollars
[Musique]
le jet d'occasion totalement repensé
dans son aménagement intérieur a ouvert
la possibilité d'acheter un jet à une
gamme plus générale de consommateurs
mais si un client peut dépenser plus
d'une dizaine de millions de dollars les
installations intérieures de luxe
représentent juste une petite partie de
ses dépenses
[Musique]
quand il s'agit de grands voyageurs sans
limite financière tous veulent le
dernier sorti des jet privé avec des
dimensions d'avion de ligne commerciale
ces avions des immenses et spacieux
bureau dans le ciel sont capables de
voler à travers tous les continents et
les océans sans se ravitailler les plus
populaires sont construits par Boeing
bombardiers Gulf Stream et Airbus
mais de tels types d'avion peut
atteindre des prix entre 35 et 50
millions de dollars donc ceux qui les
achètent possède leurs entreprises
aéroportées d'une immense valeur sur le
marché
[Musique]
je pense qu'il existe vraiment un mythe
au sujet de ceux qui possèdent ce genre
d'avion tout d'abord la plupart des
célébrités même celles qui n'ont pas
d'avion de toute façon les utilisent ils
leur sont prêtés par leurs agents ou des
propriétaires ou des studios les vrais
propriétaires et possesseurs de ces
avions sont les directeurs de grandes
corporations qui ont beaucoup d'intérêts
dans tous les coins du globe et de ce
fait énormément besoin de se déplacer
les chefs d'État font aussi partie de la
clientèle dans la fin des années 90 les
compagnies aériennes du Koweït ont
acheté trois golf stream five pour les
fonctionnaires de l'ancien gouvernement
de ce pays
un golf string 3 ou C20 a été assigné au
général Schwarzkopf au commencement de
l'opération du désert qui est devenu
déserte Storm il lui était prêté 7 jours
sur 7 24 heures sur 24 pour la semaine
c'était devenu son bureau volant son
quartier général et la meilleure façon
pour lui de communiquer avec les chefs
militaires et les conseillers de tous
les pays occidentaux
dans un concept comme celui-ci bureau
d'entreprise volant il lui fallait
évidemment de la place pour recevoir des
gens
ces phénoménales comme cet avion est
grand et spacieux vous pouvez y donner
des conférences dans une pièce
spécialement prévue à cet effet mais
aussi vous installez dans une autre vous
pouvez avoir le personnel de secrétariat
pour s'occuper de tout toutes vos
données sont reliées à votre choix au
quartier généraux d'entreprise
cette route peut être une autoroute
aéroportée qui offre une équipe de
gestionnaire du sommet de Los Angeles à
Paris Londres ou Rome ou de New York à
Tokyo sans arrêt le premier de ses
avions d'affaires à avoir une telle
puissance sur le marché mondial fut le
golf swing five en 1997 la compagnie sir
Graham fut son premier client
le G5 a été suivi par le bombardier
Global Express et le Boeing jet
d'affaires
[Musique]
les Européens ont fabriqué l'Airbus one
319 jet liner c'était un jet d'affaires
devenu disponible fin 1997
l'Airbus jet d'entreprise est comparable
dans ses dimensions ses fonctions et son
prix au bibiji avec un volume de 1800 m3
le BBJ est juste un petit peu plus grand
mais il y a d'autres différences dans sa
version 3B un système révolutionnaire
pour les atterrissages est installé il
est utilisé pour les atterrissages à
très mauvaises visibilité piste d'envol
à 50 mètres de champ visuel une capacité
opérationnelle importante qui ne se
trouve pas beaucoup habituellement sur
les avions de ligne commerciaux où les
jets d'entreprise
le BBJ et la version luxe en jet
d'affaires qui équivaut au 737 jet
commercial il est conçu surtout pour des
entreprises et client VIP l’intérieur de
la cabine d'une surface de 241 m2 et
plus grand que certains appartements
pour augmenter son autonomie la
compagnie installé le système winglets
cela accroît le passage de l'air sur
l'aile ce qui augmente de 5%
l'efficacité de BBJ d'atterrir sur une
piste courte de 1800 mètres
mais ce n'est pas tout
il est équipé du
Théas qui est le système d'action
anti-collision de la circulation
laissez-nous chercher un autre avion
dans notre voisinage pour l'éviter lui
aussi est équipé du même système qui
évite les collisions en cas de mauvaise
visibilité saute devant et avion il nous
a l'air avant que nous nous heurtions à
celui-ci
en tenant compte du réservoir du
combustible de secours ce jet d'affaires
a une autonomie maximale de 114000 km
bombardier la compagnie qui a racheté
leur jet en 1992 construit aussi un
autre jet d'affaires le Global Express
il a une longueur totale de 30 mètres et
une envergure de 28 mètres il est en
plus le seul avion de cette catégorie
construit à partir d'aucun autre modèle
de base les autres sont toujours des
arrangements d'avions déjà existants
le Global Express est vraiment l'apogée
de la technologie de l'aviation il
possède en triple tous les meilleurs
systèmes grâce à sa grande autonomie les
conçu pour voler partout et survoler non
seulement l'Atlantique mais aussi
l'océan Pacifique c'est vous dire à quel
point il peut se conformer à toutes les
exigences pour des opérations de grandes
envergures avec ces deux moteurs
tripler les systèmes est un renfort de
la sécurité dans l'éventualité d'un
arrêt d'un système il reste toujours la
possibilité des deux autres afin que
l'avion soit capable de voler sans
risque et puisse continuer son voyage
l'ordinateur de bord peut aider à faire
un diagnostic sur toutes les fautes
techniques qui peuvent survenir il le
communiquent automatiquement au poste
concerné donc si une réparation ou une
pièce est exigée cette pièce peut alors
nous être transportée pendant que
l'avion est encore en route vers sa
destination originale cette technologie
nous permet souvent de tenir les
programmes des gens sans interruption
bien qu'il y ait des problèmes
techniques de temps en temps
le Global Express a aussi la plus haute
technologie au niveau des ailes de toute
l'industrie
il est capable d'avoir une grande
flexibilité en vol il a une pointe
mobile et un bord très Nant qui lui
permet d'être très flexible sur des
collages effectués à très basse vitesse
ce jet privé peut décoller très
doucement à une vitesse de seulement 160
à l'heure bien qu'il puisse atteindre
des vitesses de croisière de 960 km/h
donc comme j'aime à le dire le Global
Express peut planer comme un papillon
parce qu'il est très docile mais il peut
voler aussi à très grande vitesse parce
qu'une fois que vous êtes en l'air il
change la structure de son aile il
arrive petit à petit très
confortablement et n'a besoin que d'une
petite piste d'atterrissage
le quatrième jet d'entreprise de cette
catégorie et le gunstream Five la cabine
offre un espace appréciable de 15 mètres
de long sur 2 mètres 50 de large
l'équipe de designer qu'il a créé selon
les désirats des clients somptueux et
spacieux
mur et plafond tapissé
boirar et bois de placage
marbre
fauteuil recouvert de cuir luxueux tout
le reste en veau et en iguane
même les sièges dans les toilettes sont
recouverts de cuir et à ce niveau de
luxe l'acheteur peut obtenir presque
tout ce qu'il veut
une discothèque a été installée elle n'a
rien à envier au plus grandes mais il y
a aussi la communication de l'armée la
plus sophistiquée qu'il soit donc toutes
les techniques connues existent dans le
golf stream que ce soit pour le sérieux
ou pour la frivolité au fil des ans tout
a été installé
S sont idéales pour les riches
en 2000 le groupe de musique les
Backstreet Boys ont affrêté un Boeing
businal jet pour leur marathon mondial
de 42000 km le groupe est parti des
États-Unis à Stockholm Sidney Tokyo Cape
Town et Rio avant de revenir pour un
dernier grand concert à New York tout
cela en senteur
avec la publicité engendrée par les jet
privé une autre tendance se dessine
dans l'atmosphère tranquille de ce
somptueux terminal de Dallas les
passagers qui voyagent ensemble peuvent
se rencontrer au juste ce délasser s'ils
arrivent un peu plus tôt avant le départ
de par sa petite dimension et sa
fréquentation moins importante ces
petits terminaux sont plus faciles à
contrôler par le personnel de sécurité
du fait de leur grande facilité à
atterrir sur de petits aéroports les
pilotes de jet privé ont la liberté de
choisir des aéroports privés plus sûrs
et moins chargés
vous êtes avec des passagers que vous
connaissez et avec lesquels vous
travaillez dans la plupart des cas les
pilotes sont vos propres pilotes ils
sont formés par votre propre
organisation payé par votre société il
vole avec vous depuis des années et des
années il s'occupe de vos bagages à
l'embarquement au débarquement ils
ferment les portes pour vous vous
donnent les consignes de sécurité c'est
un environnement sécurisant familier et
rassurant pour le passager
dans le passé toutes ces petites
attentions très personnelles étaient un
plus mais dans une époque d'insécurité
croissante dans les aéroports et les
avions c'est services ajoutent un
élément positif important au voyageur de
jet d'affaires la paix de l'esprit
pour égarer en plus votre jet privé à
côté de votre maison acheter des ordres
de jet à l'année ou encore vous associer
pour acquérir un luxueux BBJ
[Musique]
en janvier 2001 se déroulait à Tampa en
Floride le Superbowl le vendredi avant
le jeu il y avait déjà 73 réservations
de parking pour jet qui était supposé
débarquer à l'aéroport international de
Tampa et dans un autre mille avions
charter avait aussi le projet d'atterrir
trouver une place pour garer votre jet
privé n'a jamais été aussi difficile à
ce moment
[Musique]
une autre solution si vous désirez
posséder votre propre jet privé la
collectivité
[Musique]
la collectivité est un emplacement pour
garer les avions ou les propriétaires
sont transférés près de chez eux ou dans
un aéroport adjacent
un secret bien gardé ses communautés
uniques ont été des refuges pour aider
l'expansion de l'avion privé au début
des années 70
[Musique]
disons auparavant machines les Connery
un pilote ingénieur aéronautique et
futuriste a trouvé une façon d'utiliser
les aérodromes militaires abandonnés il
les a transformés en collectivité
résidentielle pour les pilotes et leurs
familles
en 1969 Konoé a développé le premier
aéroport en collectivité près de Daytona
Beach en Floride sur un ancien aérodrome
appelé Sprouse Creek aujourd'hui il y a
800 résidents propriétaires d'avion
privé à cause du bruit les jets ne sont
en principe pas autorisés mais les
propriétaires de jet commencent à
envahir ces quelques aérodromes comme
celui de Paris de Mountain Lake en
Californie situé seulement à 42 km de
l'entrée du parc national du Yosemite
j'ai souvent été appelé le pilier des
aéroports j'ai toujours désiré une
maison sur un aéroport je l'ai
maintenant avec un garage à l'arrière et
je peux aller comment taxi en lire jet
jusqu'au garage et si j'ai envie de
partir par exemple à l'aéroport de Van
news 37 minutes plus tard j'y serai
au moins un tiers des résidents de pagne
Mountain Lake ont d'ailleurs leur maison
une bande de taxi
il existe actuellement plus de 400
aéroports collectifs privés aux
États-Unis
les pies ce dont vol étaient longue de
1000 mètres tout au plus ce n'est pas un
problème pour les plus petits avions à
hélice mais les Jets ont toujours exigé
des pistes d'envol plus longues parce
qu'ils décollent et atterrissent à plus
grande vitesse à réservoir plein un jet
privé aura besoin atteindre une vitesse
de 240 km/h pour décoller quel que soit
sa charge de passagers
[Musique]
le lire jet dans lequel nous avons volé
aujourd'hui un ralentisseur en bas des
ailes cela réduit sa vitesse de
croisière de 170 km/h il peut alors
atterrir sur une piste d'envolte ainsi
que son livre de caractéristiques nous
l'indique mais s'il veut atterrir sur
une piste courte vous ne pouvez pas le
faire avec son poids brut maximum donc
quand vous voulez voler vers un plus
petit aéroport vous devez avoir moins de
poids et vous ne pouvez pas partir avec
assez de combustible pour aller plus
loin
peu nombreux sont les propriétaires de
ces aéroports privés à vouloir accepter
le jet pourtant avec l'extension de la
propriété de jet privé les spécialistes
comme clélissi se vire dans l'obligation
de trouver une solution
[Musique]
mais que se passe-t-il pour vous ou
votre compagnie si vous ne pouvez pas
vous offrir votre propre jet privé non
loin de votre maison avec votre propre
relais taxi
il existe alors une autre alternative la
multipropriété
tout le monde dans l'industrie de
l'aviation affirme que c'est sans
conteste une nouvelle idée
révolutionnaire dans les voyages aériens
[Musique]
les grandes sociétés peuvent acheter un
huitième ou un 16e ou un quart d'un jet
très cher il ne l'utilise que senteurs
par an et il paye un service mensuel
ainsi ils n'auront pas les contingences
de l'équipage de vol à former ou tout
autre chose qu'implique la propriété
d'un chat
le gourou de cet investissement
légendaire et le milliardaire Warren
Buffett il croyait si fortement en
augmentation potentielle du concept
multi-propriété en 1998 il rachète un
concept internet de la multipropriété
aérienne
[Musique]
vous savez quand vous avez l'opportunité
la chance de pouvoir acheter une
compagnie et la meilleure que vous savez
prometteuse dans l'avenir pas de
discussion vous signez le chèque
étonnamment cette idée a mis au moins 15
ans avant de voir le jour
en 1986 Richard centile président et PDG
de jet exécutive à introduit le concept
de propriété d'avion fractionnaires il a
appelé ce concept net jet parce que sa
vision de net jet était un réseau de jet
d'affaires qui couvrirait d'abord les
États-Unis puis l'Europe et enfin le
reste du monde
[Musique]
un des avantages de la multi-propriété
aérienne et que cela permet aux clients
d'acheter le montant exact des heures de
vol annuelles dont ils ont besoin
[Musique]
lorsque nous traitons avec nos
propriétaires net jet nous les aidons à
déterminer leur besoin dans une année
soit 50 heures par an ou est-ce qu'ils
ont besoin de sang ou 150 ou 200 heures
avec un choix de 12 types d'avions
différents les clients achètent
aujourd'hui la possibilité de profiter
de la plupart des principaux jets privés
sur le marché
pour moi qui peut avoir des missions de
800 km un jour et de 2400 à notre jour
avec quelques fois de nombreux
accompagnateurs et d'autres fois tout
seul la propriété fractionnaire est un
non-sens
le type de jet est dicté par la durée du
voyage un golf stream five ou un Boeing
BBJ serait l'avion parfait pour un New
York Milan ou un New York Moscou sans
escale
mais un voyage de colombius dans l'Ohio
à New York dans le New Jersey ne
nécessite pas un avion conçu pour
supporter un voyage continental le site
exchange
ultra sera parfait pour un coup moindre
mais avec autant de confort
[Musique]
cette compagnie maintient une base de
données qui régit une importante
collection d'informations du genre
quelle est la nourriture préférée du
client ce qui va gagner du temps
ce programme est conçu pour retenir les
particularités de chaque client et ainsi
fournir à nos propriétaires le meilleur
le plus commode et le vol le plus sûr
que nous pouvons avoir nous pouvons
aussi nettoyer leur avion s'occuper de
la restauration de la direction et le
conseil de nos pilotes on peut aussi
utiliser nos météorologistes pour aider
à tracer le meilleur itinéraire pour un
jour particulier et un vol particulier
le matériel que nous utilisons est d'une
grande avancée technologique il nous
permet d'analyser les choses d'une
manière très pointue ainsi le
météorologiste pourra donner
l'information avec tout ce dont il a
besoin sur une base journalière pour
accomplir ces trois facteurs sécurité
confort du passager et économie du vol
bien sûr les prix pour tous ces services
ne sont pas exactement celui d'un simple
repas disons que si vous voulez voler 50
heures par an sur un jet léger qui coûte
6 millions chez netget vous pouvez
acheter un 16e de la propriété pour la
modique somme de
375000 dollars à rajouter à cela des
frais de gestion mensuelle et une taxe
horaire pour chaque heure de vol une
restauration convenable est inclus sans
aucune charge supplémentaire
mais peut-être n'êtes-vous pas encore
tout à fait prêt à investir si tel est
le cas il existe une façon de goûter à
tous les conforts d'un avion charter
avec un minimum de dépenses
ce service s'appelle skyjet.com ils
offrent par connexion internet la
possibilité aux clients d'acheter des
sièges inutilisés sur les vols charters
d'entreprise
skyjet c'est quoi c'est une place pris
sur Internet ou client et fournisseur
d'avion peuvent se connecter notre
mission de base et de proposer une
réservation sur un jet d'affaires aussi
facilement que sur un jet commercial
Trevor Cornwell savait qu'il circulait
près de 1500 jettes à travers le pays
disponible en tant que charter
mais personne ne savait où les
répertorier il crée donc un système qui
permet de rassembler les informations et
de les mettre sur une base de données
[Musique]
vous allez passer une semaine à Los
Angeles cet avion ne va pas là il va
plus loin ou alors va dans l'autre sens
ou alors il revient en arrière pour
prendre un client
qui a réservé la place magique dans un
jet d'affaires
parce que vous pouvez en effet réserver
réellement un voyage quand l'avion vient
de laisser un client nous avons installé
un système de vente aux enchères où vous
pouvez entrer et dire je veux prendre ce
vol de New York à Los Angeles et voilà
combien je peux y mettre
le plus haute gagne le siège sur le jet
d'entreprise
Kai jet.com utilise internet comme un
outil pour connaître et gérer le nombre
exact des sièges disponibles sur les jet
d'affaires à travers tout le pays
nous avons créé un logiciel très simple
qui permet à un client d'être capable de
rentrer dans le système via Internet ou
à travers notre centre de réservation
tout un ensemble de villes reliées dans
un itinéraire où les gens expriment leur
désir sur leur destination et leur date
alors notre logiciel produit pour ce
client une liste du meilleur avion
disponible pour eux
[Musique]
une gamme d'avions quelques injustifient
leur prix d'autres fournissent le luxe
en plus et d'autres encore offrent une
plus grande vitesse pour atteindre sa
destination
le système skyjet permet à ses clients
d'acheter des sièges vides à un prix
inférieur au prix normal
[Musique]
les billets se vendent parfois pour
seulement 200 dollars pour une
destination qui habituellement aurait
coûté beaucoup plus cher
légèrement plus qu'un billet de première
classe sur une ligne aérienne
commerciale
quel que soit votre choix acheter des
heures en multipropriété ou juste un
siège est une chance de profiter d'un
voyage sur jet privé
puis viendra le nouveau système de la
ligne aérienne révolutionnaire de la
NASA avec des jets propulsés et des
aéroports de plus en plus perfectionnés
[Musique]
en 1903 lorsque ville et Wilber Wright
s'acharnent à faire voler des avions en
toile et en bois jamais il n'aurait pu
imaginer qu'il serait les précurseurs du
futur mouvements aérien
des jets sur pilote automatique seront
programmés pour éviter les collisions en
vol ainsi que décoller et atterrir sur
des aéroports perfectionnés puis
viendront les avions hypersoniques avec
leur technologie du combustion de
l'oxygène hors de l'atmosphère
[Musique]
nous avons eu des avions de ligne
pendant environ 65 ans voyage de la
ligne aérienne je pense que maintenant
quand nous regarderons en arrière ne
nous dirons que c'était une gentille
phase que nous avons traversé c'était
une époque qui est maintenant révolue et
rattrapé par de nouvelles technologies
le transport aérien supersonique
commercial est entré dans l'histoire de
l'aviation avec le Concorde en 1969
mais le Concorde n'est pas autorisé à
voler à basse altitude du fait de la
pollution phonique causée par les
changements de vitesse du son quand il
atteint Mac 1 c'est un insecte du futur
qui n'est cependant pas complètement
maîtrisé
gore streaming le golf stream n'a pas
abandonné ses rêves pour un jet
d'affaires supersonique ils sont en
préparation dans des travaux sur
lesquels travail les fabricants du
moteur de demain pour trouver une
combinaison qui puisse s'adapter à un
jet d'affaires d'entreprise
beaucoup de gens pensent que nous
devrions sauter de 1,2 Mac à 1,6 très
vite et aller droit à un jet d'affaires
hypersonique
un avion hypersonique voyageait à une
vitesse maximale de Mach 10
c'est 10 fois la vitesse que les ondes
sonores parcourt ou 11 millions 940 000
km par heure
pour accomplir cela la NASA étudie une
technologie en voie de développement
pour des moteurs qui régleraient les
mouvements de l'air par rapport à
l'atmosphère qui alors brûlerait
l'oxygène comme combustible
actuellement un trajet de San Francisco
à Atlanta ou New York à Los Angeles en
une demi-heure et une utopie pour les
voyageurs les plus pressés
mais les compagnies aériennes y songe
sérieusement
[Musique]
dans un futur plus proche de nouvelles
sons lasers sont à envisager ces sondes
mesureront la turbulence de l'air pur en
observant les particules de poussière
engendrées par de l'air en mouvement
elles en mesurant la vitesse
[Musique]
le ciel est maintenant comme de grands
boulevards grâce à toutes ces nouvelles
données votre chemin est tracé et vous
devez le suivre
la NASA effectue aussi des recherches
sur un système de ligne aériennes
nationales révolutionnaire il l'appelle
sats petit système du transport
aéroportuaire s'ils arrivent à le rendre
opérationnel le nombre de jet privé
augmentera considérablement
sa TS apportera un œil différent il va
pouvoir calculer avec grande précision
votre vol au moyen de son système de
rayon laser vous ne perdrez pas de temps
mais vous atteindrez votre destination
plus rapidement
avec les moyens actuels et le système de
recherche vous volez de Los Angeles à
Miami vous pouvez commencer la journée
par une longue attente à l'aéroport de
Los Angeles puis au lieu de voler
directement à Miami vous changez l'avion
à Dallas forwards Saint-Louis ou San
Francisco tout dépendra de la compagnie
aérienne que vous aurez choisi
[Musique]
cela peut vous rallonger votre voyage de
plusieurs heures en fait un voyage qui
devait prendre cinq heures en totalise
10 ou 12
avec sats vous serez capable de voler
directement d'un petit aéroport près de
votre maison ou de votre bureau à un
petit aéroport près de votre destination
vous gagnerez alors 5 heures ou plus
au début ces petits aéroports existant
déjà aux États-Unis serait des servi par
une flotte de taxi aérien petit jet qui
ferait des petits sauts de 800 km en
fait avayation et clips d'Albuquerque au
Nouveau-Mexique est en train de sortir
son dernier né l'éclipse 500
un petit jet tout simple de six places
avec un prix de vente prévu à seulement
838000 dollars
cet avion sera utilisé comme taxi aérien
dans la région du Nord et en Amérique du
Sud au début 2004
la NASA estime que dans 10 ans nous
verrons un changement considérable dans
la manière de voyager par avion
[Musique]
la direction de SAPS envisage pour le
futur qu'un jour vous puissiez prendre
votre téléphone portable ou votre
ordinateur sur lequel il y aura une
icône et d'un seul coup tout s'ouvrira
votre écran vous dira ah je crois que
vous êtes dans la région de San Fernando
Valley et l'aéroport le plus proche de
vous est à seulement 2 km voulez-vous
partir de là un message vous revient
alors disons que nous vous embarquons
dans tant de temps s'il y a deux autres
personnes qui veulent aller aux chutes
du Niagara si vous êtes d'accord pour
voyager avec eux le billet sera
immédiatement calculé en fonction et
imprimer est-ce que vous voulez faire
cela oui ou non
à quelle heure voulez-vous y être à 6h
ou bien le soir ce sera des voyages à la
carte
l'avion aussi bien que les aéroports
seront intelligents
gérés par ordinateur ils seront capables
de se parler les uns avec les autres en
faisant des enregistrements et des
atterrissages automatiques
l'ordinateur de l'avion ça change
parfaitement où vous voulez vous rendre
va donc calculer exactement votre trajet
et cette autoroute du ciel apparaîtra
sur l'écran sous forme d'une description
graphique intuitive du chemin du vol que
vous aurez à suivre de plus toutes les
données de temps de circulation de
terrain d'atterrissage où tous les
obstacles que vous pourriez rencontrer
avant votre destination finale auront
été résolus pourvu
la Fédération et l'industrie de
l'aviation américaine coopèrent dans cet
effort la NASA espère que sats réduira
le temps du transport pour beaucoup par
moitié dans les 10 ans à venir et des
deux tiers dans les 25 années suivantes
mais dans le futur les jets privés
pourront se préparer à cette idée
construit et testé par un promoteur
aérien rêveur birdstreten pour visionner
à Saint-Louis dans le Missouri l'avion
est appelé le Vantage
nous avons eu l'intuition de construire
un avion qui serait accessible
confortable mais aussi d'un
environnement amical
nous voulions nous assurer qu'il
comporterait tous les éléments de
sécurité mais aussi qu'il pourrait
atterrir et décoller de n'importe quel
aéroport d'une petite ville ou d'une
grande et tout cela sans changement pour
nos clients
pour construire cet avion visionnaire à
choisir un Pride Whitney ventilateur
turbo un moteur de jet connu pour être
extrêmement silencieux ils ont aussi
choisi plutôt un moteur de jet
monomoteur plutôt que celui d'un
bimoteur
challenge les moteurs de jet sont si
fiables qu'un jet d'affaires mono moteur
serait de toute façon beaucoup plus sûre
qu'un avion à hélice à deux moteurs
de plus si vous possédez un avion
monomoteur la Fédération exige que vous
le conceviez afin que sa vitesse de
croisière ou sa vitesse minimum soit
relativement basse
et cela afin de s'assurer que si vous
devenez un planeur vous puissiez
atterrir quelque part dans un champ avec
toutes vos chances de survie comparé au
peu qu'il vous resterait si vous
atterrissiez comme un jet d'affaires
banal
alors que de nombreuses entreprises
aériennes construisent leur fuselage de
jet sans matériaux composites le Vantage
serait le premier à bénéficier lui de
cette matière composite les techniques
de la construction composite utilisent
l'ordinateur pour contrôler des machines
automatisées qui tissent littéralement
la structure en fibres de carbone
individuelle et époxyde
la structure du Vantage est composée de
ce matériel qui est travaillé alors en
infuselage sans couture
vous pouvez mouler beaucoup de parties
de la carlingue et par conséquent vous
n'avez pas besoin de tous ces River
utilisées pour les autres avions ou la
construction se fait en plus petite
partie avec ses nouveaux composites vous
pouvez obtenir de belles courbes et
c'est vraiment la vague du futur la plus
grande avancée de toute l'histoire de
l'aviation en général
avec 6 passagers et un pilote
l’autonomie du Vantage serait de 2000 km
avec une vitesse de croisière maximale
de plus de 645 km/h il pourra voler à
une altitude de 12300 km et surtout il
atterrira sur une piste de seulement 750
mètres de long oui
nous présentons le départ d'un avenir
florissant pour les jets d'affaires
privées et aussi pour les jets
personnels qui vont se vendre moitié
moins cher qu'ils ne le sont
actuellement et si nous regardons le
futur nous allons avoir beaucoup des
milliers de jets à construire et de ce
fait nous commencerons à avoir des gens
formés plutôt pour les jets que pour les
avions à hélice
mais avec des plus petites jettes plus
d'aéroports et une augmentation de la
circulation aérienne la question de la
place dans le ciel reste posée
d'ailleurs certaines personnes pensent
déjà que le trafic aérien est
bouchés disent que le ciel est bouché
qu'il n'y a plus de place que le ciel
est un gigantesque autoroute
demandez-leur aussi de lever les yeux
par temps clair dans les régions les
plus congestionnées vous pouvez voir
dans un espace d'environ 32000 mètres
cubes deux avions 3 ou plus
mais dans un futur plus lointain Birds
breten envisage l'avenir avec des petits
aéroports qui fonctionnent rien un peu
comme un porte-avions actuellement un
porte-avion gaspille l'énergie dépensé
lors de l'atterrissage d'un avion reyton
croit que cette énergie peut être
utilisée
[Musique]
en fait mon idée consiste à construire
20 petits aéroports en centre-ville en
les empilant
quand un avion arrive dedans il décélère
pendant 60 à 90 mètres alors l'énergie
de ralentissement de cet avion est
utilisé pour accélérer le prochain vol
de départ
cela pourrait être beaucoup plus
tranquille et beaucoup plus commode en
un seul siècle nous sommes passés des
chevaux au chariot puis à deux voitures
dans chaque garage
quel que soit la longueur de l'avenir de
la gamme des jets privés il est clair
que la façon dont nous avançons avec les
grands avions de ligne et les aéroports
aujourd'hui nous entraînent vers de
grandes transformations
les jets privés peuvent écrire le
prochain chapitre de notre histoire du
transport
[Musique]
pour faire une comparaison imagée dans
le siècle dernier nous avons équipé
l'Amérique avec des roues je ne pense
pas être trop optimiste en disant que de
la même façon au vin du même siècle nous
pourrions lui mettre des ailes
[Musique]